you
[Music]
Neera took us on no Sacchi Anna Hallie
see another sake ERISA Kashi what those
characters are speaking isn't gibberish
it's actually a language called Dothraki
and it was invented by this guy David
Peterson in lovely Orange County
California David Peterson is what we
call a con Langer and inventor of
languages coddling is the intentional
creation of a full language creating its
full grammar it's full phonology it's a
writing system if it has one and its
entire lexicon david has written many
languages but the first one he wrote was
back in 2000 I was taking an intro
linguistics class at UC Berkeley in 2000
and it was just one day during class I
started scribbling on my no it's my very
first language he named it after his
girlfriend named Davi and according to
David himself it's irredeemably awful
it's just not it's not worth it even
considering anymore everything I was
doing with this language was just a kind
of really fancy bizarre way to speak
English so I kind of just started over
and said all right ground zero how do I
be a language creator before we move
forward let's take a quick step back and
talk about the Godfather of modern
calling j.r.r tolkien you probably know
this name because he's the author of The
Hobbit and Lord of the Rings
he created fourteen different languages
for use within middle-earth Quenya and
Sindarin are probably his most famous he
was the very first person that we know
of to create languages just for fun and
we've been kind of emulating him ever
since now that we've cleared that up we
can move forward
we're here in California because we're
curious about what it takes to create a
successful language David's having two
of his friends who are also con langurs
come over and speak with us one of them
brought ice cream we were gonna do this
outside but it's too hot so we're gonna
do it inside the three of them are
talking about how languages are created
and they've come up with five steps take
it away guys all right a naturalistic
online means five basic things one the
people what they do who their neighbors
are the second thing that you're going
to need is a phonology or sound system
do you have voiced and voiceless
consonants do you have aspirated
consonants three words all the nouns all
the verbs all the modifiers fourth
grammar which is the fun part
finally history you know how the
meanings of words changed over time and
you need to know how the grammar of your
language evolved from a time in the
distant past to what's used now now that
we've got that settled let's finish this
in the past 15 years somebody who
created language went from somebody who
was like oh you're a nerd too you know
oh wow that's that's really nerdy which
now means cool and it's prolific use in
television and film proves that it's not
just a passing fancy
for television the difference between a
created language and some other set prop
is that the maximum level of interaction
that if you were ever has with a
background set or with a prop is just
seeing it on-screen a language on the
other hand when you hear it that's the
that's the most real a language ever
gets for that reason you have to have a
fully created language for a television
show and not just a bunch of gibberish
what's that good thank God
swordmaking has always been an esoteric
endeavored there's never been a great
number of people doing it you have this
transformation of raw material the
alteration of nature and in the end you
get something that just exudes power
[Music]
this is Valyrian steel my father saw the
ancient swords on Game of Thrones forged
with Valyrian steel were stronger and
lighter than any other weapon no one
knows how they were made in the real
world over a thousand years ago in
Viking lands there was also a series of
special swords with mysterious origins
and a blacksmith in Wisconsin tried to
make one this is an old Bert sword from
about 850 to maybe early 1200s in viking
controlled lands you had a sword that
had a name inlay called wolf bert which
roughly translates to wolf tooth or wolf
bear it's a word of power there are only
350 known ulfberht swords forged with
the quality of Steel that didn't emerge
in Europe for another thousand years no
one knows exactly how they were made I
think I've come fairly close or at least
a pretty good rendition of how they made
those blades steel is a pretty special
material we know a great deal about it
and we know almost nothing about it so
with the old Bert you have a mythical
steel mirrored in the game of thrones
where you have this deal that no one's
able to reproduce that black Valyrian
steel sword making technology still
holds a bit of alchemy a bit of
mysticism in it we want to believe that
there's something that we can't
understand there's still mysteries in
steel
[Music]
except for the horses really any animal
that has been seen on Game of Thrones
comes from our farm the sheep we goat
the pigs I was going through difficult
times but Game of Thrones led to a whole
different world for me here I was a wee
farmer from kinda Yamaha it just blew me
away
at the start Kenny Gracie foretold farm
in northern and on the farm we have the
old traditional breed animals that are
native to the British Isles namely the
longhorn cattle Jacob sheep and
Saddleback pigs
I was been through difficult times and
I'm not ashamed to admit as I was
struggling I was approached by Game of
Thrones and they asked that I supplied
rare and traditional animals for their
production I said yeah of course and so
this was a godsend to me Joey I know
darling
good boy Game of Thrones afforded me the
luxury so to speak of doing what I love
and that is working with animals being
the animal Hamzah and taking my animals
out on set a lot of the people recognize
the affection that I have for them and
the love
[Music]
as far back as I can remember I've
always loved animals and they've always
been delivered my life that affection
that you shew to an animal I think they
showed back tenfold
[Music]
in the forests of Southeast Asia high up
in the treetops a mythical creature
lives it turns out dragons are real
so I have to call a biologist I'm
Anthony Russell from the department of
biological sciences at the University of
Calgary in Alberta Canada we're talking
about a species of flying lizards so
it's called Draco Volans which means
flying dragon
okay these flying dragons they are a
little different from the dragons we see
in movies first starters they're small
oh yeah they are only about eight inches
long and they don't breathe fire but
they do fly in a way they're gliders
which means they have control of their
descent and trajectory but they don't
have any power in it for every one foot
they go down in vertical distance
they'll be able to travel six feet alone
that's because they don't actually have
wings there are actually modifications
of the ribs so they're nothing to do
with the legs and arms evolutionarily
speaking this has helped the lizards
survive they can escape attacks and they
have a broader living zone so they might
not be dragon dragons
sometimes people name things because
it's more dramatic effect well they're
still incredible lizards
[Music]
why I like to save the goats that's a
question I have often been asking myself
because I can't answer it this is
somehow my mission to take care of the
goats somebody had to do it
and I fall in love with them my name is
Johanna Burt Massaro stuffed it and I'm
a goat farmer in Iceland for the last 16
years I have been trying to build up and
protect or goat breed they have been
isolated in Iceland for 1,100 years they
came by the Vikings from Norway and from
Scotland and Ireland
though I haven't gota twice been less
than 100 animals in 1962 they was just
about 60 70 goats left they have been a
very big tension of loss in breeding and
disappearing I got them here and since
then it helped in my passion to breed up
this type of the gods
this is the only farm we are trying to
live from the coats to milk lamb and
make products if you are trying to save
a breed you have to use what they give
we have been doing lots of different
things to raise attention for the goats
and Game of Thrones for shooting here 20
of the goats were used
they would not be here anymore if I
wouldn't have taken care of them I'm
very proud to look at my floss and see
that they are life because of my work
it's just like when you have children
you are proud of them I'm very proud of
my goats
[Music]